today we're going to be speaking with
dan cannon who's a civil rights lawyer
and a law professor at the university of
louisville he's also author of the book
pleading out how plea bargaining creates
a permanent criminal class
dan really great having you on i
appreciate your time hi david thanks for
having me so i mean i think maybe to
start it would it would make sense to
talk about how this sort of like a plea
deal industrial complex started i think
many of us intuitively know just because
you've been charged with a crime doesn't
mean that there will eventually be a
trial and a verdict in the way that we
watch uh sometimes on television and in
major trials
how did this develop that many cases
don't make it to trial whose motive who
was motivated to make that the reality
sure and i would i would go so far as to
say um almost all cases don't make it to
trial where we're sitting at right now
is a 97 plea bargain rate which is you
know just to sort of grasp the the how
big that is um you know that's that's
three out of every
out of every hundred criminal cases that
might go to trial right you know on
average and that's the entire country
this is way way way far beyond what
anybody else is doing in the rest of the
world the rest of the world you know
even in in comparable um
legal systems places like the united
kingdom and canada and so on i mean the
highest you get is to 80 percent and
even that is kind of extreme so nobody
does it as much as we do and and what
the result has been
pretty much the death of the jury trial
all together for all intents and
purposes the community has been
completely removed from processes of
criminal justice
and if you look historically at
how and why this originated you know
it's the uniquely american thing that we
do you've got to go back all the way to
the beginning of the 19th century
and look at the early labor movement in
the united states and when that was
gathering steam that is at the same time
that that is the same time that the plea
bargain sort of took off in new england
right so you have this post-industrial
revolution situation where the working
classes are getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and up until 1830
you know plea bargaining was taboo there
was i mean you would see prosecutors
actually get prosecuted for
trying to make deals with defendants in
the way that they do now so it was
completely off the table and just wasn't
happening or if it was happening we
didn't know about it
then in massachusetts you see that
number tick up
very quickly by the 1850s it's 50
percent of all criminal cases are ending
in a a guilty plea
by the 1880s it's 88 percent right so
almost all
uh criminal cases are ending in a guilty
plea by the end of the 19th century in
massachusetts
and what's happening there is that
there's this this giant explosion of
working-class people right and at the
beginning in the 1830s the courts and
every other american institution is
working really really hard to break the
back of organized labor you've got
the first strikes are happening in the
1820s
and then the first federation of labor
unions happens in new york in 1834
and so the ruling classes are sort of
panicking and coming trying to figure
out you know how to how to fix this
whole thing first thing they start doing
is prosecuting groups of workers under
conspiracy statutes uh so you get big
groups of them at a time and say all
right you know you're going to get
together and try to get higher wages or
you know
shorter work days or something like that
and we're going to prosecute you for a
conspiracy
and it becomes pretty apparent
early on that that's that's not going to
work by the 1840s they've sort of
scrapped that whole idea because there's
just too many of them and
there's this the working classes are
getting too big and there's
working-class people for the first time
sitting on these criminal juries
so the response of the ruling classes at
that time as i as i talk about my book
is to number one take a lot of power
away from juries juries are not nearly
as powerful now as they were back then
and the other one is to introduce the
plea bargain so what that allows them to
do is to quickly and quietly prosecute
lots of individual workers one by one
rather than trying to smack a whole
bunch of them at a time with the
the hammer of the criminal law which
they knew that wasn't going to work they
were just too outnumbered
in the modern era
what is the advantage we'll talk first
about the prosecutors i mean it seems
if everybody went to trial they would
not have nearly the workforce that would
be required to try that number of cases
right i mean it just seems like an
impossibility yeah yeah so what you see
in situations where the in the few
situations where um you've actually
reduced the number of plea bargains
is that it does force prosecutors to
make tough decisions okay
so you look at the historical example of
alaska for a very brief period of time
in alaska you had an attorney general
come in and say
you know this is uh we're going to stop
doing plea bargaining we're going to
reduce the number of plea bars like all
the plea bargains are going to come
through me yep and and what i've heard
since i was in law school is that if
somebody does something like that it's
going to crash the whole system right
we're just not going to have a criminal
justice system anymore because the
wheels of justice are going to stop
turning and you know all these jury
trials are going to make it to where we
just can't do anything right but that's
not true if you look at the historical
example of alaska and some of these
other places where this has happened
what happened in alaska was
lots more cases went to trial um but the
system didn't crash it adapted and it
got more intelligent so at the point in
time in
alaska where this new attorney general
took over
the alaskan prosecutors were rejecting
about four percent of all the cases that
police brought to them so cops would
come in with a case and if it was a bad
case if it was a good case it didn't
matter because the prosecutors knew that
they could push somebody into some kind
of plea bargain and and get a conviction
right
taking plea bargaining off the table
means that the prosecutors have to be
more selective and so what happens right
off the bat is that the prosecutors go
from rejecting four percent of all those
cases to rejecting 40 percent
so that forces prosecutors to to make
decisions right to to come up with
priorities for what they're going to
prosecute and what they're really you
know what the community's um uh
priorities really are
um
and and so far from crashing the system
um
it adapts it becomes more intelligent
the prosecutors are making more
intelligent decisions and that forces
the police to cross their t's and dot
their eyes and do more diligent um
homework so if you think about the
situation that we have now you know
police know they're going to get a
conviction they know that they're going
to you know they they
out of
most of the 11 million arrests that
happen in the united states every year
are going to result in some kind of
conviction
um and so they don't have to
have any real evidence that a crime was
committed they don't have to you know uh
they're not anticipating that they're
ever going to be put on the stand
or have to account for
the charges that they've levied against
somebody in any sort of meaningful way
and and if you reduce the number of plea
bargain cases even just by a little bit
that whole situation starts to change
because police know that the case is
more likely to go to trial and so they
have to be more careful in what they
bring to prosecutors in the first place
now from the standpoint of the
defendants the accused i think many of
us have this instinct that if we were
ever in such a situation and we felt
that we were innocent we would fight to
the end and demand a jury trial and so
on and so forth what are the incentives
that are there for those who are charged
to end up taking plea deals well it's
every incentive in the world isn't it
you know so so that's what we've decided
to do in the united states that's so
different from the rest of the world
here we've decided that we're going to
give every carrot and every stick to
prosecutors so they can end up with a
conviction somehow right
so um and this was all still sorting
itself out by the late 20th century
and then there was this supreme court
case called borden kercher versus hayes
where you have right down the road here
in lexington kentucky you've got
a 29 year old black horse transporter
who um gets picked up for trying to cash
a bad check worth 88 right so he writes
a bad check
prosecutor comes to him says well it
looks like you were in trouble 10 years
ago over something and so
what you're going to do is for this 88
dollar check you're going to take five
years in prison
and paul hayes says i don't want to take
five years in prison prosecutor says
well if you don't take five years in
prison
then i'm going to hit you with this
habitual offender charge and that
carries a mandatory penalty of life in
prison
and that
he's like i don't want to do life in
prison over an 88 check but that's the
kind of power the prosecutor has
we're still sort of sorting out whether
or not we wanted to do that
in that case paul hayes
didn't want to take the deal he went to
trial got convicted and got a life
sentence
and that case went all the way up to the
supreme court the supreme court at that
time in 1978 essentially says yeah you
know it's the prosecutor's job to
persuade a defendant to give up their
right to trial
and they can do that by hook or by crook
they can do whatever they want to get a
defendant to to to plead guilty and to
forego the as the prosecutor says the
inconvenience of the trial
um and so that case sort of throws the
floodgates open
uh for prosecutors to use anything and
everything that they want
so you know if you have um if you're
charged with murder let's say
you know the prosecutor can offer
carrots can say look you know we're
going to bust these charges down to a
wanton endangerment and you're going to
do six months probation because i just
don't want to take it to trial and i
don't think it's a very good case but i
need a conviction so you know take it or
leave it and you'd be hard-pressed to
say i'm going to leave that on the table
right conversely if a prosecutor wants
to
proceed as though it is a death penalty
case
and threaten a defendant with literal
death if they don't take uh a plea
bargain to let's say life without prison
they can do that too and in fact when
you look at the numbers one of the more
chilling statistics that i've got in my
book is that since the 1970s 75 percent
of the people on death row
could have avoided a death sentence by
taking the plea offer that the
prosecutor gave to them so in other
words the prosecutor has the power to
say you know if you don't take this deal
i'm going to put the death sentence on
the tables not on the table until you
take until you say yes or no but if you
make me go to trial well death penalty
is on the table so prosecutors just had
this enormous power
to alter the legal landscape in any
given case that in the united states
that they just don't have in other
countries
is it easier for wealthier defendants to
avoid taking plea deals in the sense
that all else being equal
a long trial costs more money
sure uh for for for reasons that i said
before it's long trials cost more money
but they're also you know uh more high
profile
right they're they're more visible to
the public uh the media pays more
attention to what's going on in these
high-profile cases so you get somebody
like a jeffrey epstein that's going to
come in with you know it's
quite obviously is is is guilty but
comes in with a team
of you know 100 high paid lawyers
that are going to make the prosecution
work
uh
for for anything that they end up with
and so the prosecutor starts to look at
that situation saying all right this is
going to be very time consuming it's
going to be very difficult it's going to
be very expensive
and it could be very humiliating if we
lose right you know this is this this
could have political consequences and
all this other stuff
and it's going to be very much in the
public eye
so rather than go through you know the
the hoops of a trial
uh let's try to get them into a place
where they're going to take a plea and
in fact that is exactly what happened
down in florida with jeffrey epstein and
the the initial uh disastrous
prosecution that
fed's tried to carry on there
and and the victims were completely cut
out of that prosecution and um epstein
got a slap on the wrist for you know
abhorrent conduct um and that is the
kind of treatment that um that the
wealthy typically can expect to receive
in the united states so when people talk
about there being two different justice
systems here that's that's what they
mean it seems the other component to
this also is the use of pre-trial
detention and the ability to make bail i
mean as a very general concept i think
it's probably more difficult to mount a
defense
all else being equal if you are being
detained up until the time of your trial
rather than out can can you talk a
little bit about that and the effect of
pre-trial detention and possibly the
unequal application of pre-trial
detention on the the sort of plea
bargain chances i guess
sure so cash bail like the plea bargain
is one of those things that we've
carried forward you know from an overtly
classist system in the 19th century
until now
right so you know it's yet another gun
that a prosecution that the prosecution
can put to a defendant's head to say
like listen you know if you don't take
this deal you're just going to stay
locked up there until we have a trial
and that could be two years from now
that could be three years from now so if
you can't post bail tough luck there you
sit in the county jail and these county
jails as i'm sure you know are
oftentimes not friendly places they're
so unfriendly in fact especially
metropolitan jails are so unfriendly
that you see defendants taking deals
where they end up going to prison just
because prisons are a little friendlier
than the county jail right for example
you see that a lot
but but basically it's it's this arsenal
of tools that the prosecution has
cash bail being one of them to make sure
that some that that every defendant gets
pressed into taking a deal of some kind
i had a client that i represented in a
civil rights case who insisted on his
innocence in uh in these criminal
charges that were levied against him way
out in rural kentucky
and
he sat there in jail waiting for his
trial to come up for three years well
the maximum sentence that he could have
come up with
that he he could have been subjected to
was only two years wow on the original
charges so he sits there in three years
waiting for his trial and then goes to
trial and no police show up and they
dismiss the charges you know um and and
so that is the kind of thing that for
people that insist on their right to
trial they're going to get punished for
it it's what we call the trial penalty
it's what happened to paul hayes it's
what's happened to countless clients
that i've had and it's what happens all
over america every single day in those
situations um i think this was an issue
with with donziger in fact
when the strictest penalty you could get
is less than the time that you've been
detained pre-trial
is there some recourse or remedy in
those cases
well you'd think there would be right
you'd think that and and that's that was
you know the case with my guy down in
eastern kentucky yeah um but the federal
courts are so hostile uh in most of the
country to the civil rights actions that
you're not very likely to get anyway and
especially since this is such a common
thing like for people to stay in jail
way longer than they should stay in jail
for one reason or another yeah um that
you know most most of those folks that
have been aggrieved by something like
that in the system
can't even find a civil lawyer to
represent them to to certain to
vindicate their rights certainly not in
rural parts of the country where this
happens all the time
and when they do find someone to
represent them the civil rights actions
tend to fall flat on their face because
you've got these
judges that are hostile to these kinds
of actions to begin with right
the book is pleading out how plea
bargaining creates a permanent criminal
class we've been speaking to the book's
author law professor dan cannon dan
thank you so much for your time thanks
so much for having me